welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy whose videos
you say nope to as soon as ryanairy has
his out jordan peel is one of the best
names in horror right now and we've just
got our first look at the director's new
film nope normally when i do trailer
breakdowns i watch them once or twice
and get most of the gist of what's going
on but this is a real mystery i've now
gone over it 10 times and i can't figure
out exactly what's happening in the
movie there are a lot of clues to what
the film's about throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
and if you enjoy it we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up also make sure
you subscribe as we've got a ton of
trailer breakdowns coming for the super
bowl and you definitely don't want to
miss them with that out the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our trailer breakdown of nope
okay so nope is so mysterious that we
don't even have character names so i
don't really know what to call those in
it however we do know that the family
the film is centered around will be
called hayward and the two main
characters will be played by kiki palmer
and daniel kaluya the teaser opens with
kiki's character discussing the history
of motion pictures and how her great
great great grandfather was the person
who starred in the first one this was
assembled by edward mybridge who is
pretty much considered the father of
motion pictures my bridge was actually
commissioned to create the piece in
order to prove that at some point in the
gallop all four of a horse's legs were
off the ground shutters were unable to
capture this at the time because the
speed of the legs just came out as a
blur more times than not and those
several images were compiled in order to
prove the point whilst my bridge is
loaded as the creator the rider is often
overlooked i think that peel may be very
much discussing how black figures are
often cast to the side in an artistic
and historical sense his work often
deals with social and racial issues and
thus i think it's a fair assumption to
make that this movie will at least be
going over elements like that too if
we're taking the trailer on a
metaphorical level it could be
commentary on the storm that surrounds
hollywood and it may tackle things like
the metoo movement or other aspects
obviously i'm just guessing here and it
is a bit difficult to judge what a
director is trying to say based of a
teaser that gives very little away now
the motion picture has very much led the
family into a legacy of horses in
hollywood and we learned that they run
the only black owned horse training
ranch in the entire area this is called
hayward's hollywood horses and ever
since the beginning they've had skin in
the game if it's about horses though
they shouldn't have called it nope they
should have called it nay now i think
that the opening of this trailer will
either be for an advertisement or
documentary as they're filming it on a
sound stage and even the horse has a
little motion tracker on it i'm kind of
leaning more towards the documentary
angle as kiki is giving her all whereas
daniel isn't she's clearly dropping a
sales pitch whereas he's just rolling
his eyes and probably just wants to talk
about the history where she's selling
the business if it was a commercial i
think he'd be a lot more enthusiastic
and we also have an extensive camera
crew there which would be more than
what's needed for a short commercial
they all sort of roll our eyes too and
intercut with this is basically a tour
of the ranch now the place is littered
with wacky waving inflatable arm
flailing tube men wacky waving
inflatable arm flailing two man wacky
waving inflatable arm failing tube man
wacky waving inflatable arm flailing too
mad
normally when we see these they're stood
proudly but all these ones are slumped
over and as we know from us and get out
peele loves to lice his films with
iconography that's symbolic i think the
sales pitch tied in with the down tube
men signifies that the business isn't
doing too well miracles are later
mentioned and it could be that the storm
ends up clearing out all the other
ranches in the area which leads to the
haywards finally getting some business
we do see lights off in the distance at
what's likely another farm and these end
up shutting off later on they also
encounter a man who potentially lives on
a ranch he's staring often in the sky
but behind the haywards we can see what
appears to be a van with the name fries
on it there also seems to be a snake so
potentially this is another animal
handler in the area now over the top of
this scene we can hear the song fingers
by stevie wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the opening of this has stevie saying
yeah over and over again and the word
yeah is of course an opposite to nope
the power cuts out at the farm too and
then the title sequence starts to roll
in this appears very similar to how the
titles and credits dropped in on the
shining and peelers often cited that
movie as being one of his favorites his
previous horrors had several callbacks
to the movie and we've done a full
breakdown on get out which will be
linked at the end if you want to know
more although it seems like this is
initially just a storm after watching
the trailer several times i think it's
clear that this is an alien invasion
science did a great job of showing one
from the perspective of a farmer and his
family i think that this will follow the
exact same lines just in the same way
that us could have stood for united
states nope could potentially stand for
none of planet earth at one point in the
trailer we can see what appears to be a
ship in the sky and daniel's character
looks at this black ufo as it flies
through the night the poster for the
film has an ominous cloud with a kite
dangling from it which is a shot that
also appears in this teaser you can see
the rain from above the ship coming off
the sides and the craft is so big that
it's stopping any of it from hitting
daniel i think that the aliens are
likely coming to clear out the ranches
disguised as clouds and we do get
several shots at tease towards what they
look like the first of these comes when
we catch several soft toys that look
like they have alien heads some of the
pigs snouts this appears to be at the
event that steven young later attends
which i'm guessing is rodeo later on in
the teaser we see a large round head
that looks similar these toys poking
over the top of a fence and thus i think
they will look very similar to this
there's also a baby's hand that reaches
out to a bloody monkey ball looking
thing that could also be them this looks
like a toy though so i don't know maybe
they take over the toys small soldiers
too anyone anyway they clearly have
control of the elements and throughout
they blast the window characters
surrounding them in sand perhaps the
storms completely stop in the area and
this is what the miracle that daniel is
referring to we do see a farmer later on
being surrounded in san and dust from
the ground and this could be the aliens
potentially attacking him on top of this
there are other shots laced throughout
the teaser that are clearly put in place
in order to unsettle us this includes a
crab and also the eye of a reptile which
stares directly into the camera amongst
a quick shot is also a woman who looks
like she suffered from severe burns the
veil she wears to cover her face has
been blown slightly and she's looking up
at the sky this is meridian several of
the characters that appear who all seem
to be looking up at something though we
don't know what but i do
aliens now we end with a shot from the
ship's point of view as they chase
daniel's character on horseback and his
sister is lifted into the air after
being covered in a blanket of sand might
be his wife as well i don't know yet
they don't they don't let us know but
overall it's a really intriguing trailer
and no i think i have somewhat of grasp
of it now i also still have no idea
what's going on and i like that about
the movie peeler's great at crafting
original and memorable stories and i
love the sinister vibe that this entire
thing has we have a lot of great actors
in it too and i can't wait to try and
uncover the mystery of exactly what's
going on in the movie is it aliens is it
evil toys is it horses turning against
their masters i really don't know but
i'm here for it and i can't wait until
the movie releases in july this year
after long delays due to the pandemic it
finally feels like we're getting the
good stuff and hopefully you enjoyed the
breakdown also apologies for my voice
i've got a really bad throw at the
moment i'm fine yeah don't worry but
just in case i sound a little more
cracked than usual now whilst i recover
i'd love to hear your thoughts so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in competition right now giving
away three copies of the june box set on
the 28th of feb and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now save that
to you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of get out which will be
linked on screen right now we went over
all the hidden iconography in it so
definitely go check it out right after
this without the way thank you for
sending through the video i've been poor
i'll see you on the next one take care
peace